after World War II most of Europe was
split into East and West with all of
these countries becoming a part of the
USSR sphere of influence notably to the
South Greece despite mostly bordering
communist countries and having a large
communist resistance never joined the
Eastern block which raises the question
why why didn't Greece become a Soviet
puppet in the Cold War so as of 1943
there were many in the UK who could see
that the writing was on the wall for
Germany and that eventually the USSR
would Triumph whilst Churchill was happy
to see the defeat of the axis he was
less pleased about the idea of a Soviet
dominated Europe and as such he came up
with an idea to stop the USSR was making
sure that they were the ones to destroy
Germany the plan was to use the US
military to conquer North Africa and
then invade Italy from there the Allies
would quickly move into the Balkans to
stop the Red Army before it could get
through Romania however there was one
problem with this plan it was insane by
1944 Churchill realized this and so he
sought to negotiate with the USSR to
preserve some of EAS andn South Europe's
independence from communism which which
would be done by maintaining their
monarchies now US President Franklin D
Roosevelt didn't approve of this and so
to make negotiations with Stalin simpler
Churchill simply didn't invite him as
such the UK and USSR agreed to what's
known as the percentages agreement
whereby each country in the region would
be subject to a certain amount of
influence from the west or the USSR to
start Romania would be 100% in the
Soviet camp and have no Western
influence whatsoever Yugoslavia would be
split 50/50 Bulgaria and Hungary would
overwhelmingly come under Soviet
influence but the West could maintain a
presence there whereas Greece would see
its government aligned with the west but
the Communist party there would be
permitted to run in elections as you'll
know though this agreement wasn't worth
much since it wasn't long before all of
these countries soon had Communist
governments and wanted little to do with
the West so why didn't this happen to
Greece well the main answer was
geography Greece's location meant that
if it were to fall into the Communist
Camp it could potentially be used as a
naval base to disrupt British shipping
through the Mediterranean as such the
British were happy to make use of former
collaborators as well as anyone else who
wasn't a communist unsurprised
surprisingly this led to conflict
between British troops and Greek
resistance Fighters and Stalin opted to
stay out of it his reason was that he
knew the Britain saw a communist Greece
as a near existential threat to its
Empire and so would never willingly back
down and thus it would be better to try
and maintain some semblance of friendly
relations over a country that wasn't all
that important to Moscow furthermore
Stalin believed that if the USSR
provided direct Aid the USA would do so
too and thus Greece's Communists would
actually be much more likely to succeed
with the help that they were getting
from Yugoslavia and Albania but when the
USSR and Yugoslavia fell out that a
dried up too leaving the Greek
Communists on their own and when the
United States got involved anyway their
fate was largely sealed and by 1949
Greece's position as a member of the
western capitalist world was assured I
hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons James Bizet
Kelly moneymaker Sky Chappelle Katka
Andy McGee Alex Schwin AF Firefly Marcus
arner Spencer Lightfoot Wan hockey
Marvin CAU Captain pdogg boogly wgly
kimon Yun Winston kwood Gustav Swan khed
Alder Wood Maggie patkowski the mppa
Anthony Becket calling Dr Howard Dr Fine
Dr Howard copper tone shenin spinning
three plates words about books podcast
rod D Martin Jim Stromberg Miss iset and
Charles I